nouveau conseil d'agglomération en
octobre et un petit nouveau dans
l'assemblée mustapha larbaoui devient
élus communautaires de la ville de
trappes c'est en remplacement d'hotman
nassr ou démissionnaire est devenu
premier vice président de la région ile
de france l'a aujourd'hui le rendement
des enceintes où il se prend des
décisions importantes
voilà laquelle je suis associé
maintenant et donc c'est impressionnant
et pour le coup ça me fait très plaisir
de représenter les trappistes à la
communauté d'agglomération et de
participer aux travaux de toute l'agglo
au menu de la séance près de 40 des
libérations désignation des
représentants de l'agglomération au sein
des différents conseils d'administration
elles notamment pour la pépinière promo
paul et la mission locale ce qui est 16
les élus communautaires se sont
prononcés favorablement aussi pour un
nouveau projet concernant la ferme de
bus loyer à magny les hameaux
soixante dix pour 3 contre création sur
place prochainement d'une ferme école
qui formera aux métiers de l'agriculture
bio et qui sera géré par l'association
graines d'avenir
c'est un projet qui a été portée par
tous la ferme de belloy y est c'est un
élément historique essentiel bertrand ou
lyon on parlera mieux que moi puisque
c'est sur sa commune nous avons à cet
endroit là une ferme qui je ne remonte
pas au moyen-âge mais dans l'histoire
plus récente celle de la ville nouvelle
et le lieu qui a accueilli
l'établissement public d'aménagement qui
a réalisé la l'élaboration et la
construction de la ville nouvelle donc
il fallait trouver une nouvelle
destination à ce site une ferme huit
hectares c'est compliqué on a pu trouver
un projet qui concilie social
environnement le conseil d'agglomération
a également voté pour la création d'une
piste cyclable à lille de loisirs sites
olympiques de paris 2024
saint-quentin-en-yvelines contribuera à
hauteur de 220 mille euros sur l'île de
loisirs nous n'avions pas de piste
cyclable donc évidemment pour sept
points la sportif en lien avec les jo
c'était important
il ya un autre point essentiel aussi
c'est qu'aujourd'hui il y à un grand
nombre de salariés qui arrive à la gare
de montigny saint quentin en yvelines et
qui se rendent à la clé saint-pierre et
leur permettre demain d'avoir une piste
cyclable qui leur permet de se rendre à
vélo jusqu'à leur lieu de travail et
vice versa le soient c'est une très
belle évolution que nous souhaitons au
niveau des mobilités sur saint quentin
en yvelines
parmi les autres décisions à retenir
notamment le soutien de saint quentin en
yvelines à hauteur de 105 mille euros
pour la construction de logements
sociaux aux clayes-sous-bois prochaine
séance le 19 novembre à 19h30